but as soon as you get up to that second
knuckle it's like it hurts like you know
that's like I'm not gay I'm not gay I'm
not good like I'm not gay
hey I'm Ari shafir this is Robert Kelly
we're here to answer the internet oh
wait I need glasses okay can you pass my
glasses from over there how long would
you have to starve to become a cannibal
uh 48 minutes
as someone who eats [ __ ] all the time
I'm already a cannonball give it to me
yeah easy one bring it
no rules case match who would you choose
oh damn
why didn't Trump would be sick I do
Madonna and Roseanne
[ __ ] great with Daddy and then at the
end they just start eating each other
out 69 the worst way oh my god oh nice
nice
I just hit the camera
I have another one for two people
fighting it'd be it'd be like it'd be
like uh who's who's like uh who's the
best boxer right now
uh
Tyson Fury and like somebody extremely
weak like Greta Thornburg and just
[ __ ] no offensive kind of Thunderbird
but man I like violence
and just [ __ ] Cambridge [ __ ] skull
and it's his oh yeah she's coming out of
the closet next month uh who's the
number one celebrity or athlete you want
to see come back to life
Thai cop dude the [ __ ] he would say oh
my God would be wild it would blow up
the internet Ty Cobb would be like
what's happened since I've been gone
I mean why damn it Ty Cobb is a [ __ ]
well that's old school yeah he'd bring
his spikes out of my not even wearing
these
I would say I would be like I hate all
these blocks except Kanye you're making
some good points and making me rethink
my black hatred I would say Elvis Elvis
would be nice yeah cause you know he'd
probably come to The Cellar we'd hang
with him yeah I gotta go school's
opening
would you rather lose your ability to
taste food or to feel sex
good if someone only does one but um
I hope you get hit by a bus
this is your last special I really do I
hope you don't die though I hope
something had you through into a cup and
we have to wheel you around and every
year Barstow does a benefit for you
treat me like Patrice in those last two
days
it's his best friend
would you rather [ __ ] that first of all
I want to prove this language but okay
internet would you rather [ __ ] the
hottest girl celebrity who has a dick a
man or Vin Diesel with a [ __ ]
I'm not I'd [ __ ] do the dick chick
yeah Vin Diesel's too emotional he'd
want to cuddle you know that dick
chicken be like all right get out of
here who would you put a dick on and
[ __ ] her like if it was your choice be
who would I put it's a regular female
celebrity add a dick to it yeah it's
like a Margot Robbie um who's Wonder
Woman uh Gail Gadot yes
[ __ ] wouldn't be a hawk it wouldn't be
like she wouldn't be like mess with the
[ __ ] thing you know yeah
nice piece yeah like shriveled [ __ ]
Thailand yeah no she'd have a nice piece
you think so nice helmet Israeli should
have big balls
who cares we roll the dice we'd have
some dice you me that's you wouldn't let
go if you're with galvano you'd be like
let's just go remember that movie uh
Rockstar with Mark Wahlberg and the next
day and he banged that chicken she's
pissed and standing up come on every guy
in the theater had a popcorn on the lap
would you rather a sit on a cake and eat
a dick B sit on a dick and eat a cake oh
this is post-surgery question
because I put stuff in my butt and you
think it's gonna feel good but as soon
as you get up to that second knuckle
it's like it hurts like you know that's
like I'm not gay I'm not gay
there's no cleanup from eating a cake
there is something yeah there's a lot of
cleanup his jizz dripping out of your
[ __ ] you think I'm not gonna make
them come if I'm gonna do it yeah yeah
but dripping off your face you got two
cleanups for one it's not it's not a
good thing either way a lot of these ask
the internets you're thinking one's good
it's not as good in a lot of these
questions yeah but you can shoot it over
your shoulder you could take it no you
spit it oh you know you're a winner
you're not gonna do it that way you're
gonna commit yeah you're right maybe
you're right you're right you know what
you're right you're right I'll just do
anything how fast yeah you're right if
you have the opportunity to turn someone
into a [ __ ] who would it be oh that's
interesting yeah it is trying someone
into a [ __ ] oh the problem with this
you want to get the right one but it's
like so many people I think Trump would
be a good one yeah
someone who yeah probably a good one all
respects of the king but like uh yeah he
loves his stature yeah
yeah maybe it's Donald Trump and a
[ __ ] that might not be bad I'd like
you as a [ __ ] oh yeah with the same
noise
you have to also always be standing like
this
it's not funny I can't get my little
shirt over the head
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out